Good morning, gentlemen. We're interviewing you
today for a YouTube channel called
Singer View. We'd like to
get a little perspective on
finance. We'll start with
inequality, by the way. We'll give the floor to
Hervé de Carmoy. Hervé de Carmoy, what
can you tell us about the
inequalities he encounters in the United States?
He encounters them while the
American population is growing. There are 50
million South Americans today; in 25 years there will
be 130 million. There are
16 million Asians today; there will be
40 million. So how do we see this? It's
because white people—that is,
those who are not South American,
Black, or Asian—are fifteen times
richer than others. That's a fact. And
wage inequality
continues to increase.
When I was working in the
American automotive industry,
the CEO of General Motors earned 30
times more than the worker. Today it's
400 times more. So there's a
significant increase in inequality. That's the
point.  And you, as a
citizen, when you see this
crazy increase in inequality, what do
you think the
social repercussions will be for
the American population, and
perhaps for the world population? For the
American population, the
repercussions won't be like those seen
in France.
Americans aren't going to revolt.
Why? Because it's a huge country,
and the
population is spread across a
continent, so it will be slow. But there is
a beginning of rejection of these inequalities, which
explains why the current president of the United States is
placing so much emphasis on reducing
inequalities. And why have
inequalities increased? Because
the salaries of people who have started
and created businesses are in
the billions of dollars, and you have
hundreds of thousands of middle managers
who are seeing their standard of living
decline. Why? Because education has
increased considerably. You could
go to an American university for
$20,000 a year; today it costs
eighty thousand. And because the cost
of healthcare has exploded. Philippe Béchade, what
can you tell me about what
Hervé is giving us like this?
Information is,
can you sprinkle
a little of the Google/Facebook gaffes into your reasoning?
California wants
to secede. California, well, it's more like
Silicon Valley Classic in
Valais, which wants to secede
from California, which
perhaps even wants to establish bases
outside international waters to
create its own rules. Philippe G.,
already bouncing back on the question of
education,
indeed, we're looking at about fifteen
years, practically
a tripling of
tuition fees for job
opportunities that unfortunately
aren't infinitely expandable
since there are a huge number of
engineering positions that have been
relocated to India. I'm talking
specifically about computer science, so only
research positions remain in the United States. Very, very often,
when you look at the composition of the
American Congress,
senators
and
representatives, you realize that
more than 70% of them come from six
American universities, which we
all know, namely
Harvard. He
loves Haiti.  And it's
Cambridge itself, well, they're the most
expensive and they're the ones that
most easily provide access to a field of study that's practically
the
royal road to an elected office, namely
law, or
business management.
A successful businessman, like
Mitt Romney, tries at some point
to become a politician. So
here we have a kind of
reproduction of the elite
because all these people co-opt each other,
because they send their children to the
same universities, and they're very
expensive, they become completely
inaccessible. So that's a factor of 10. There's no
idea of ​​inequality simply
because the fields that lead to the
top of the pyramid
today are reserved for those who
have already acquired the means. You have to
rethink your opinion on co-
optation, the inbreeding of certain
elites who make the
majority of decisions. It's something that
obviously shocks our audience, whether
French, Italian, or Swedish.
Danish, because in Denmark not only
are studies free, but some
students are even
paid, between 700 and 800 euros per month,
which allows them to finance at least
a room and their studies. So I'll close
this parenthesis here. In the
United States, no, it's not shocking at all.
Everything costs money, and quality comes at a price.
So today, there isn't
really anything shocking about
it. It doesn't shock the population to
think that little by little, studies are
becoming completely inaccessible. There's
a scholarship system that allows a
few very deserving students to access the
right programs. But
apart from that, it doesn't really shock
the average American. Deserving students, according to the
political quotient, are now being treated
as deserving, with this
bias of trying to favor so-called visible
minorities.
So, allowing access to
children of the second generation of
Chinese, Latino, and other immigrants to access education
very quickly. Regarding what's
happening in California, well, there too...
It's noticeable that those who succeed today in
creating companies that manage to secure
funding also come from the
best technological universities, and
once you've
succeeded, the big challenge today
isn't just maintaining
American
technological supremacy for a company, it's
also about completely freeing yourself from
the American tax system.
Companies that have now
become
multinationals have a tax rate
of 8% on profits, and even the
most cunning and proactive ones, in
terms of
shifting their profits to
tax havens, can't seem to get
their average tax rate down to 5%.
So, let's pick up on that with
Olivier Berlioux from Vie Bergie. Hello, hello. What
can you tell us about the tax rate of large companies like Facebook and Google?
Can you also talk about the
Luxembourg leaks? Yes, we're listening.
I'd like to start by going back to the topic of
inequality,
reminding you that it's a phenomenon that has affected the
entire Western world since...  The
seventies, in any case, it's a
phenomenon that started in the United States and
affected the United States very strongly, the
Anglo-Saxon world quite strongly,
and then, in a somewhat more
moderate way, countries like Germany, France, and
Italy. The consequences of this
mental shift—because what you have to
understand is that, obviously,
the arrival of Ronald Reagan in the
United States accelerated this movement, this
growth of inequality—but what's
quite interesting is that it's
truly theorized; it's a doctrine, a
doctrine, and it's perhaps the
first time in history that we've seen this. In fact,
when you seek more
inequality, thinking that ultimately
the rich will get richer, well, there will be a trickle-down effect
on the
poorest, and that will enrich the country, which
is truly new.
Even the American liberals of the
late 18th century, who were very
liberal and had few steps, said that the
goal would be 15 radios.
Ultimately, the goal here is to increase inequality.
I can ask you a
slightly more personal question: do you
think this is a way to
select the most dangerous or the
most corrupt, to favor the greediest among
us, the most aggressive in business?
In any case, it's a way
to further enrich the elite, the
American elite. We know that the wealthiest few percent in the
United States own
half to half of the wealth. We're
really talking about levels in the United States,
somewhat conscious in Europe, but which
are insane in terms
of inequality. And obviously, the
consequences of this movement are
obviously not to enrich the
bourgeoisie, or in some way, the new
aristocracy,
the new nobility. The new Russian nobility is
a woman, a true nobility, whereas it will
be financial, which will also
sometimes be medical there, given the
specificities of the healthcare model in the
United States, which are the lawyers. So
basically, it's the trader, it's the trader, the
CEO.  The lawyer and the doctor who end up with incomes
of several
million euros per year, the
consequences are felt for several hours in
the obvious lover, the social consequence is
and everyone can see what it can do, seeing it
in terms of
social disintegration, a growth of
inequalities, even if, as Hervé said,
in the particular case of the Americans, we
are a society that holds up quite well against
this model since there
really is an idea in the United States,
two sites to play, it's your fault and
everyone waits for Lloris to say, well yes, well
I don't know, I'm broke, but I'm
bad, actually, I could have become
president of the United States, like
Obama didn't, so it's my
fault, there is not necessarily
reasoning in saying yes, wait for me, I couldn't
go to school because it
costs an arm and a leg, with the banker
not following me, what
is also interesting is that she
believes there are
economic effects, they are extremely
important in terms of capturing the
wealth produced by a sector that is
ultimately unproductive, if  I give 1000
euros to an American worker; it's worth
consuming locally and shopping,
so it will boost the economy. If
I give another 1000 euros to
a multimillionaire
American lawyer, what will he do with it?
Well, he'll invest it in
financial markets, which will be
outside the GAFA group, like TD Bull, which we know, and which might even
speculate on
the ruble in Russia. Who knows? In
any case, it will be removed from
the real economy, and therefore, what has an
influence is, of course, on the
growth packages that the Western world is experiencing.
Countries in general are still growing, and in the
United States, we're at 2.5 percent, 2 to 3 percent
growth. If we look at it per capita, there's only
2.5 percent. If
I remove the
undeclared South American residents, it's more
than 2% per capita. That's
certainly more than in Europe,
but we don't have very detailed analyses on that.
But it's quite  Clearly, from
Piketty's work on
inequality in the United States, if you
look at the 90% of the population who
earn less, or perhaps the 80s and
90s, within this mass of the
US, which has probably been in recession since
2008, it's the top 10% who
perhaps have 10% growth per year,
which ultimately gives you a
small growth of 2%. But you
have to understand that a country that is sinking has
a significant portion that is sinking, while
a portion is doing very, very, very well,
particularly by
also considering the business leaders
we were talking about earlier, who
are good at avoiding paying taxes. What
is eating away at them will
come back to haunt you. Regarding
Luxembourg, Olivier Delamarche, what
can you say a
little bit about what has just been said? The
symbolic elected official of inequality,
tax evasion through Ireland, and
major players like Google and Facebook are all
red flags.  And the mistake is more about
food stamps, okay, it cost, it's not that
round, yes, if we want to give
figures, you have roughly 50
million Americans, a little less than
50 million Americans who are into
football, this theme, then you have 60% of
American households who cannot
cope with an expense of $400 without
borrowing the $400 or having it lent to them by
their relatives,
we stick to the figures, give you the
figures, they are published by
the BLS, by
the BEA, and the various surveys of
the Philadelphia Fed, and so
you have today
an acceleration of poverty in the United States
like we haven't seen
since the 1930s, so it's
true that you also have
student loans which are the likely new
bubble
behind probably the
oil bubble, but you have a bubble that has
formed because
the costs would be borne to cope with
studies are increasingly important
and today
the problem is that the  Opportunities are dwindling,
meaning
you have to help kids who
need $80,000 to
study and can't find a
job except as a waiter, which
will make it difficult to repay the
$80,000. So you have a whole
host of things that have
deteriorated considerably over the last
five or six years, since 2008. And
despite a considerable rise
from Standard to a race, but that only
pleases the two or three Americans who have shares in Luxembourg.
Nothing
extraordinary to say. What
shocks me today is that we're busy
chasing away the
few individuals who
invested $200,000 in Basel, Switzerland,
but we happily continue with
Ireland, which is why we
only want to maintain it in Europe because it's
when  Even such a contribution that
it is necessary to keep them in the euro and which
allows companies, large
multinationals, to pay only 7 or 8%
tax when they pay 7 or 8% because
when they are
powerful enough and negotiate even 6%, and so there you have it,
I mean, we are in a kind of scapegoat situation, targeting the
individual who, for example,
put 100,000 francs
aside in Switzerland, and then, thanks to that, manages to
escape a billion, 3
billion in taxes, that doesn't bother anyone
and there's no problem, Hervé. To summarize the
situation, you all explained, the
four of you trivially put together the things
that there is an American doctrine
projected onto finance, a doctrine you
discussed with Pierre, a
strategic business expert, a
strategy projected onto Europe, the
consequences of finance, do
you anticipate them as well, its
unequal consequences, what do you
anticipate on Europe,
Hervé?
Inevitably,
but where does it come from? The source of the main
difference between the United States and us, the
United States refused  For some
time now, in order to control their banks, they have
refused to see that
American banks have taken enormous risks.
First, the primary source, Deyris, and the
1970 American regulations that
authorized interest on demand deposits. Since demand
deposits were now
earning interest, whereas they weren't
before, American banks experienced a
huge loss of revenue. Could you
briefly explain what a
demand deposit is for our listeners? A demand
deposit is when you have a
few thousand euros that you haven't
invested in
1-month, 3-month, or 1-year deposits, or
in stocks that are essentially sitting idle
in your account.
Well, that represents hundreds of
billions of dollars. It
represented 30 to 40% of the
banks' liquidity funding. They used
the deposits of individuals and
businesses that were there, or
placed in their accounts, and that didn't
move much. So, the government took those deposits, and the government
said they had to be paid interest.
And since they had to pay interest, it led to
A
40 to 50% decrease in bank profitability
depending on interest rates.
This transformation
led banks to ask themselves how they were going to make
money. Then there was a
second phase: they authorized, they
stopped the link between gold and the dollar.
American banks were given
permission to massively increase
their balance sheets. Thirty years ago, a
bank's balance sheet couldn't be more
than 10 or 11 percent larger than its
equity.
Today, depending on the bank, we're seeing
leverage ratios 50, 80, or even 90 times greater. Leverage ratios of 90 to
90... This explains why there are
currently ten thousand American banks
since 2008 that have gone
bankrupt because they overextended themselves. Because
regulations have changed...
You're talking about regulations. To
return to my initial question,
the Luxembourg leaks...
we saw someone exfiltrate
information concerning...  Jean-Claude
Juncker, who allegedly organized
or facilitated tax evasion
for traitors with major
global players, is now at the
head of Europe. Don't you think
the regulations are
rigged or flawed from the start? That is to
say, we have elites who are
co-opted, or at least selected for their
aggressiveness, their ability
to reason, or to perpetuate a system. Don't
you think these so-
called Luxembourgs, these so-called
Luxembourgs, are the very epitome
of this political and financial cowardice?
Listen, we can't deny it: there's
a tolerance towards the 2-2 of
European aid workers who break the law
regarding income tax returns and
asset declarations that deserves
to be challenged. But where can we challenge it?
On what grounds are you challenging it?
I completely agree with you. There was
an investigation,
and some MEPs were
pressured to withdraw from the whole
investigation. Vince, a world that  Lack of
courage.
It is essential to have
representatives of the population who act
in the long-term interest of the
population, and that these enormous capital flows
deposited in Luxembourg
should have been
elsewhere, in order to serve the
community of countries that constitute
Europe. This may require
statesmen, not
career politicians. So,
the choice of people is a
big question. How is it that we
are elected? What do we have to show
to be elected? Does
indicating that we will penalize the
rich, that we will uphold the
general fiscal interest, and that we will take the
necessary measures, get you
elected? You're playing games, I'm playing games, and I have a bit of a
question mark. Olivier
Bourrouilh, and
yes, it's an illustration that fraud
is ultimately at the heart of the system,
and this is true in many,
many, many areas. It's
well observed that when the banks went
bankrupt in 2008, they had to be
urgently recapitalized. Obviously  In the
end, there were practically no
sanctions, for sure, for sure, for sure, on the
leaders. No sanctions were instituted.
What is this bonus? And this bonus is quite a lot.
Thousands upon thousands of frauds, from the CEO down to the lowest-level
employee, from the smallest
brokers who, when they saw
an American with 5,000 euros of income per
year, would say, "We had fifty thousand..." He could have been
gay. All the declarations to
pass off Sallabank, but I, who had
no prosecution, unlike those we were
browsing in the late 80s, and was spared. Savings bank in the
late
80s in the United States, these are...  Hundreds of
trials, there have been practically
000 here. I have two out-of-bounds cases: the Rolling
Stones, who offered me choices,
Luxembourg, the X. Well, it's an example
that we, without drinking, participated in
the tax evasion of two of its
European neighbors, as
Ireland does, as the Netherlands does, and
this time Belgium,
on certain points. So we show you this, it
shows that there is no solidarity in
interstate Europe, and the idea is to
try to fleece the neighbor and have had to
steal their tax base.
We even make it
a model of those of those of this system
in the end, but we have
total responsibility. This sense is quite
striking in this very
system in which we are not
what we sometimes say. It is liberal,
ultraliberal in some aspects, yes, we
see very well in some aspects. Yes, it
can be based on theories 1-2,
total deregulation in the style of Milton
Friedman, but in the ultraliberal theory,
it broke down, in
any case, a form of coherence at some
point.  There is a sanction, but
when banks are regulated, after a
while, the days when a bank has
a problem, it goes bankrupt,
end of story. There's no guarantee
to hold people accountable. So, in
any case, in liberal theory, there comes a
point of responsibility, a
sanction, people going to prison. We
see that today there is none, or even that we
promote those who have made
mistakes. We are
told about the beautiful European model, yet there is
no solidarity. That being said, it's
our fault, too. We shouldn't look too closely at what
Google or
Apple are doing. From the moment
we create a zone in Europe with fewer
borders and haven't harmonized
rates, obviously, there will be some
idiot somewhere who will be less
honest. Beijing—in the
general philosophy—will implement, like Ireland,
a tax rate on profits of
5 or 10%. Obviously,
everyone will go there, just as if you
wanted to set up your business in the
States.  If you're told that in Texas there's a 5% tax rate, it's
32 in New York, and
think about it, you're going to... I think
you're going to Texas. So the problem is,
why did we do
this? And in conclusion, I find it so
extraordinary that they put Juncker in the
presidency of the Commission because we see that with
this title, he organized
tax fraud in Dorthe. It's to
show his vision, Jega, see just a
little word, Lyon Coeur, a good one. When he
has economic problems, who does he talk to?
Pierre
Moscovici, obviously the
economic winner in Europe. And at worst,
Moscovici won't say anything so that we take care
of France. He picks up the
phone, who answers? Harlem Désir, a
Minister for European Affairs, Pierre, who screwed over the Socialist Party, put him
there because he
had to be extracted from the Socialist Party. He said, "
Where do we put him? Do we dedicate it to him?" Read again. Actually,
no, wait, we're going to appoint him Minister for
European Affairs. Seriously, it
may seem like a sketch, but...  From a distance,
this story... I'll...
I'll pass the floor to you right away.
After that, I remember a
story about a
worried American president, and on the 10th of the
month, a relative who said, at the end of
the Black Thursday crisis, that he was
bombarded with
banking regulations because he
knew the environment very well, that
you think he's a Kennedy, the
Joker?
I read that he did a lot of honor, I
think. Okay, no,
but lol. So, what I was saying, I completely
agree with Olivier, but
the worst part is that it's like that in every
country: China (excluding Hong Kong), the
United States, the Seven Seas... we have it in
absolutely every country. We're
talking about it here in Europe because it's the
topic of the day, but you have it
absolutely everywhere. So, systems
that allow for the diversion of
state taxes, which, it's true, have become
sprawling. So there's a
safety valve, that's what I suppose, that's how
I play it, in any case, the
politicians.  It's about saying to yourself, you have to
offer a way out at some point, but the
universities, we're stupid, and a system that's
completely corrupt. Do
n't judge. If you have, every
year, you have
some organization that
publishes a list of countries and their
corruption levels, and France is
very well ranked, very, very well, in the
negative. So there you go, we know they're
corrupt, we know that, and
unfortunately, we know there are no
sanctions. I completely
agree with Olivier. Hello, you'll
have criminal sanctions for
someone who blows up a
bank
because today, for nothing, you
have a fine at BNP of 7 billion
dollars, 2.7 billion euros per year, 10 billion
dollars, 7 billion
euros. What happened? The
boss doesn't care at all, he writes
a check, but who do they pay?
We do. You're at BNP, right?
No, Senoussi, everywhere anyway,
it's less than a bridge  So everywhere, because
they also have him, they've put him in
charge of the type, which is huge.
Generally, Germans don't have
tax deductions, but here it's deductible
because it's BNP Paribas, so we pay him.
But on the other hand, the profits go to the
boss, and then when he speaks, they
offer him a nice job. Yes, yes, yes, the
risk was getting 10 years in jail.
He thinks twice before doing
stupid things, Philippe. I think that's
the very definition of what we call
plutocracy, quite simply,
collusion between business
and political circles. I have
several
observations to make regarding
the responsibility of politicians. There's no
after-sales service once
you've elected someone. The
decisions that will be made,
those that will completely escape the
citizens' notice,
unfortunately, there's nothing to be done. You take
a government like the French one
where you see that out of 30 ministers, there are
two who have worked in
business, who have a  From my limited
experience in the business world, the others
are mostly
professional politicians; they aren't specialists
in anything. So, when a somewhat
complex decision needs to be made
regarding taxation or
how the
banking system should function, it's the
specialists within the
political sphere who handle
the follow-up and processing of
files. Then, it's put to a
vote in the assembly. People don't really know what's going on
because it's
too complicated. Even the government does
n't understand much of what actually happened.
And in the end, we
realize there are consequences.
If people had been aware before
casting their ballots, they would have
said, "Whatever you do, don't do that!" That's the thing; it's
to our
detriment. It only benefits
a small circle of people
who control practically all the
financial levers. So, there's
absolutely no way to control it afterward.
When you've bypassed politics, and it's
politics that entrusts
the implementation
of European regulations, and so on, there's
no control.
Are you finished? That's right, there's
no control. I just had
one question. Yes, go ahead. Quite
political, quite crazy. Do they want to
blind these crowds or these politicians to gouge their
eyes out? It's either one or
the other. Are we somewhere in between right now?
That is to say,
the voter doesn't have the time, due to
economic stress, to really take an interest in
the politics of the city, or is it really
orchestrated so that they are
completely one-eyed,
completely blind to how
things are going? I'm going back
to something simple: there are
laws, these laws are not
respected regarding fraud,
regarding concealment,
they are not respected. We don't have to
complain
to the leaders. All those
responsible for
social issues, newspapers, and
public authorities must decide to apply the law. We have everything we need,
Hervé. The budget
for the STIS administration, and in France, it's
less than the budget for ecology,
but I know, but he  Perhaps
the state needs to decide to
significantly increase the budget of the
Ministry of Justice, with the
prospect of recovering billions.
But it's there, and some countries are doing it.
I can tell you that the
tax fraud we're talking about is infinitely
less prevalent in Great Britain than
on the continent. It's less
prevalent because the sanctions and the
way files are investigated, how they're brought to light, whether
people are multi-billionaires or not, are
stronger. So we
must encourage our
national justice system to take very
strict measures to
force people not to conceal their tax returns
when they find them, to take the money.
I'm going to give the floor to Olivier
Delamarche. Just before that, we'd like to pay a
small tribute to Denis
Robert for his investigation
into Clearstream. He's a journalist who doesn't want to be silenced,
and we'll see him tomorrow for the
premiere of a film that summarizes
his investigation. Olivier Delamarche, you
wanted to respond, yes, but I
simply wish you... the
main problem is that we no longer have...  Since de
Gaulle, statesmen have clearly been replaced by
scooter brokers, by people with little
interest who are far from
being up to the challenges
and the current crisis. So, as long as we have
people like that, who all
respect the Peter Principle, who
are incompetent, placed there because
they think they'll do less harm where
they are—and unfortunately, I think they
do a lot of harm where they
are—we'll have this type of reaction.
Why would you want these people to
increase the budget of the Ministry of
Justice when they are at the
mercy of the public and all
the risks they face? They
risk everything if the laws are applied:
prison for a long time. So,
they're not going to shoot themselves in the
foot, quite simply. They don't
want
things to evolve like this at all; they're quite
comfortable. This is the new nobility of
politicians in Europe; it's the
new nobility, meaning they
have all the  rights that are absolutely
unaccountable to anyone,
and
ultimately they live very well and have no
intention whatsoever of changing
anything that would put them at
risk. In this case, we shouldn't
count on politicians to
divulge this type of information. Should we
instead rely on
popular initiatives or
platforms like this one to divulge
information and generate a
popular outcry that pushes the justice system to bring
people to justice, to put them in
their place? You're a bit like those CGT union
stalls in power that only dream of it. It's only by
watching the 8
o'clock news that you'll see what they like, okay?
And it's not by
listening to the speeches of a Pierre
Moscovici or others. So there are still a few
things that lift us out of the
zero level of reflection,
Philippe. Yes, I find popular outrage
sometimes
refreshing, even perhaps
beneficial. The problem is that it
often manifests itself as a rise of
extremists, people who instinctively...
They understand something's wrong, that they're just trying to cover it up.
They don't know
exactly when
things are happening, they don't know that in
behind every MEP there
were three or four lobbyists.
Today there are still around 570
MEPs, there are 15,000 lobbyists.
They all act in the name of
financial interests, apart from a few NGOs that have
also had some lobbyists trying
to do something. And when we
look at the spread of
pressure exerted on some and
others today, we realize that since we
often put people in the European Parliament whom we're
trying to recycle because they haven't
succeeded in their own
country, they aren't specialists. And when
a great specialist, a top
international lawyer from a major firm
based in London or Luxembourg, comes to
explain that this new law that
the Brussels parliament is going to try to
pass is for a purpose that is obviously
to harm
the community and serve
some special interests,
the MEPs are  Totally
permeable, and obviously, as I told you earlier, there's no
control whatsoever
regarding the AVS (Old-Age and Survivors' Insurance). They were able to recover a
lot of money; it's obviously in
the black holes of European taxation,
the famous "Luxembourg slicks." What does that mean?
Simply that Luxembourg grants
a multinational the
possibility of negotiating a flat-rate
tax agreement for the next 18 to 24 months. It's
perfectly legal, it's clean.
But I'm coming back to that: what do
you think of the Macron law that was
withdrawn concerning trade secrets? Trade
secrets...
I sincerely think we did the right thing. Well, there have been
many reactions, coming from both the
media and people who
have become a little more aware of what it was about.
That is to say, if this
law passed, it would mean that any
company could
sue anyone on the
pretext that it could harm the smooth
running of its business. But it's
simply a bit of an extension of its...
an extension of taffeta, that's what it is.  Yes,
but I know taffeta, but for now,
we don't really know what's in it.
No, the democratization, the negotiations
remain secret. However, the only
thing we're pretty sure of is that it's going to be done.
Why? Companies have even more
leeway,
but all the companies that use
large consulting firms
accentuate it, and that's
basically what local laws
allow. Everything is clean, everything is legal.
What Luxembourg did is legal. It's
totally indefensible from a
moral point of view, but it's perfectly
legal. Ireland, which doesn't tax or taxes very
little on the profits of Facebook, Apple, etc.,
is perfectly legal. That is to say,
another small American company is
routing capital flows through
Ireland where they aren't taxed, and
Ireland isn't taxing it either because
the decision to route
capital through Ireland was made in the
United States, so it's not me.  It's not
me, it's nobody, and all that, it's
perfectly legal, so the day
we tackle that, we'll actually make
progress. But imagine the unanimity we'll manage to achieve
among
multinationals to agree to
taxation in a way that might be more
harmonious. Olivier, yes,
I want to go back to what we were saying earlier.
So, a bit late to the party, with some perhaps somewhat
general remarks, but generally,
when we look at
societal organization, an
interesting analytical framework is to look at
how it's organized in terms of
freedom and equality.
We saw a societal model
based on equality,
which is very, very far from going bankrupt
after 70 years. In the 80s,
obviously, the communist model,
which didn't work, even if there was
real equality in poverty. For one
port, everyone, the gulag for everyone, somewhere
to extend a whole range of models,
really a model of equality. Well, the
impression I have, which
isn't very, very  Not
very optimistic, but we are witnessing a
flight from a model based on
absolute freedom, a model whose
roots go back to the
1960s. There's a kind of impression
that after the war, after a
sclerotic society, we saw freedom, which
is abnormal, and that we have a somewhat
pathological level where freedom
becomes absolute and crushes everything.
And that's what we're experiencing. Obviously, if
I want freedom, no more
banking regulations, for example, I
want to do what I want, I want to run
my activities,
I want to say what I want, regardless of
the consequences.
I want to go and take care of what's
happening in this or that country,
because I consider it a
superior value. In any case, a model like
this, ten pairs of hyper-freedom, which
ultimately, when we pull it, obviously gives rise to
a liberal and flourishing mode of life, but also to
individualism. Especially since what
is more
liberal than the rampant individualism
I'm dealing with, regardless
of what's happening, is
a bit disheartening.  This is the kind of heating that
also affects our society, with the
consequences we were talking about
earlier. Olive, as we were studying earlier, the
system needs a safety valve somewhere, like
tax havens. But anyway, in
the late 1940s in the United States, the
income tax rate was
over 90%. The marginal rate, when
Reagan and Thatcher came to power in the late
1970s, was
70%.
Today in France, it's around 45%.
So we can see that we're already very
far from what was perceived as the
minimum standard of solidarity during the post-war boom. We
see that today it seems to have gone up
to 46%. It's
communism that's arriving, and in a way,
this almost justifies fraud.
So it clearly shows that there's a
deep problem. And finally, if
I try to get involved there, I want to see
politicians who won't try to pull the wool over my eyes on this.
A politician who
talks to me about the common good will...
No, there isn't a
very strong audience, maybe that also
plays a role in what we're currently experiencing.
So, of course, professionalism has an
impact, but after all, in the
60s, no
political class was professionalized enough to prevent having
politicians who were true heads
of state and who led us to...
Besides, there was no need to
join 28 European countries to have
a France that illuminates, that
truly undermines the entire planet. So that's
a line of thought. All of this pushes us towards
a society
we were talking about earlier, about
sandstone, what do you say these ten months, how much do you earn?
I'll tell you if you've succeeded in
life. That's what it's like to have Macron who will
tell us that the frac is rather young, who
wants to be a billionaire. If there were
two or three who wanted to be
deep in place, it could also prevent us from having
small problems in the
coming moments. We see that we ca
n't find them. So all of that was...  There's a slightly depressing
side to it. I don't have an
answer, and I'm playing a good game.
Everything that's said is true. It
comes and goes strongly right now
through Paul Volcker. To go back to what
the fundamental values
of the banking profession have been, which is what I
know and has practiced for
half a century, these values ​​were:
know your customer, act in
your customer's long-term interest, and think about what's
good for
the community you belong to, from
clients to society, your country. Well,
45 years ago, having worked with
the Americans, we were judged specifically on
how we put
these values ​​into practice. Well,
since then we've drifted, we've drifted
massively, and the reality is that  A
man named Paul
R is trying to get back to basics.
He's trying to tell American banks, "
The government has authorized you to have 3
% equity, that is, 3.32
euros of equity and 97% of credit. I
recommend you aim for 7%." He tells them, in a condescending manner,
that boards
of directors should stop giving
their executives bonuses of 5, 10, or 15 million euros. He
tells them, "You shouldn't have the right. You
shouldn't have more than 3% of
your balance sheet used in
speculative operations."
My concern for the future of the
United States is that these basic recommendations
and values ​​are not being
heeded sufficiently in the
United States and elsewhere. Philippe, the
Volcker Regulation—
listen, it's simply about going back on what
was done in '96, '97, and '98 while
Bill Clinton was busy struggling
with Monica Lewinsky—
Messrs. Robin, then
Secretary of the Treasury,
and Alan  Greenspan
completely overhauled
the rules separating investment
banking from
commercial and deposit banking activities. They
reversed the decisions made in
1933 or 1934,
which effectively
secured a portion—mostly
customer deposits—while allowing the bank to
invest a little in the markets based on the equity of its
investment banking division.
So,
Bill Clinton and the
Glass-Steagall Act were
buried.
Bill Clinton completely let it happen, and
the US Congress also let it happen. This led
to
banks that can create
money without limits, thanks to the
Fed's building neglect policy. The Fed said, "Any
loan request you make,
I'll give you the money. It's up to you
to see if your clients are
creditworthy or not. But I, the
Fed, only monitor the banks that
are on my radar."
Regarding the subprime mortgage crisis, these were
firms that placed loans and
then
went to the bank saying, "Here, I have
a pile of..."  Files of people who
wanted a loan left there, it was
the bank that
was handling the file at that time, and
volumes of derivatives this year, how much is it? Well, it's
a drop in the ocean, it's
another area. We're back, I
think, to 750 trillion in derivatives,
70% of which are credit derivatives,
50 million billion, no, no, we were getting
to a million, that is to say, we're going to get there, we're going to get there, we're going to get there,
one day a million billion
because with the money that the ECB is going to
put on the table, indeed,
if we extend the curve
reasonably, we'll reach a million
billion by the end of 2004, that's for
the NOx, it's just an anecdote, the
numbers don't mean anything anymore. So
after the Clintonian deregulation phase,
then the "big yen" phase
where it was decided that the rich would no longer pay,
or hardly any, taxes,
neither on income nor especially on capital gains,
if finally we
institute a 15% tax rate in the United States
% since 95% of the
wealthiest people's income comes from
securities income, so that
was the second step. Now,
the third step, which we are
witnessing now, is that of
massive tax evasion and tax optimization. And where companies,
contrary to what
you mentioned,
were judged on their
patriotism, today a
multinational international bank has a
playing field that is the entire planet. And
you have UBS or Credit Suisse that come
hunting for millionaires or
billionaires in the United States to
provoke them, politely offer
tax optimization solutions. So
today, banks are global, and of course,
they have a global vision of
taxation. And the global vision of
taxation is that by manipulating all
the tricks, they manage to reduce the tax rate
below 7 to 8 on average.
To say that the situation is worse than what
you say, because here, the end
of a breaker is trying to restore some
discipline and some tics, but
Alongside commercial banks,
a financial industry has emerged that represents as much as
the American GDP, 23 trillion
dollars, which is
called shadow banking, the
London Stock Exchange, or the London Stock Exchange. The ounce of this massive
surface area, London,
we are friends of Hervé, writes, the London Stock Exchange,
which represents as much as the
American GDP and is flourishing and
controlled by no one. Therefore, the
pure American banking risk, the banks
that haven't failed, Sam Elliott, and the
American financial risk, in my
opinion, is deteriorating. The project is the same, that is to
say, in fact, shadow
banking, it is done by whom, it is done
by Goldman Sachs, by
JP, by everyone, so stop, it is
an emanation of the banks, so in
any case, to the system, the
American banking system, it is
always more at risk, but exactly as, that's what's
fascinating, that is to
say, there is, there is 2008 coming, which
is  A hammer blow
to banking risk, which should have
opened the eyes of
leaders and the banking system, has in
fact not happened at all.
Six years later, we find ourselves in a
situation worse than the day before
2008, and everyone has the impression that
everything is fine because, of course, they
sell you ridiculous stress tests, they
sell you, they market you, they
tell you every day that BNP is
great, that we have the best
possible banks, that we have absolutely no
risk anywhere. But that's false; we have
more risk than before. And so,
you see, Mr.
Wolker is doing everything he can, but he has
already done everything he
can to help. The end of
the 2008 crisis isn't going to put up
new curtains in 2009. He arrived
saying that we needed to rebuild a six-
goal contract, but nobody
listened to him. He knows he was, he was
very likely the best
central banker the United States has ever had.
It's true that we prefer to
watch Ms. Jelen's body language
rather than Mr. Wolker's words, which are
much more interesting. Mary J.
Olivier,
no, indeed, I share this view. It's quite
disheartening to see that we
ultimately narrowly avoided the abyss we didn't have in
2008. We played Russian roulette; in
fact, we put in a bullet, it turned,
we fired, and now they come and
tell you, "Very well, you're
rude, look, we played, it worked well, let's do it all again." Enough of that,
but
now at least five bullets have been
fired. No lessons have been learned.
I think there are plenty of lessons that have been learned.
The banks thought, "Hey,
if there's a debate, the state will come, or the
central bank, now that we have it well under
control, will
eventually print money
to refinance us." It's really, I
repeat, quite a model of fraud.
Is this the thing that
governments should have reacted to? Good
government in the United States, we know very well
that it's in the hands of the bankers.
Such are the directors, the
ministers of the economy or finance in the
United States; most of the time it's
the former CEO of Goldman Sachs House and the
future CEO of Goldman Sachs. Here, we have
Emmanuel Macron. These are
symbols that are
quite astonishing. We see that we have
clean, respectable people. Don't accuse them; they are
in their
system. I even sometimes agree with him.
This declaration from AXA,
which is taken somewhere, is a
Gesvres. I see the glory of God, angry.
I'm doing Bourdieu, basically, and I think they
think, and it's not some kind of
megalomania like that. It's
cocaine, yes, maybe,
but in any case, with consequences
that would have been enough. Seriously,
viewing them on amounts that are
gigantic,
Walter, on the amount of derivatives, you
have to know that on average the maximum risk
is about 10% of the
notional amount that you  As mentioned earlier,
when we see that it poses a risk, and that
at least at the level of global GDP,
ten times the global GDP, it's falling back on
a game that's always cut off, and I'm going to
ask you for your opinion on the
media coverage of this type of information. So, we come from
networks, from
the internet, where
people are being spied on, we're really a
collaborative intelligence plugin, we
really get information coming from
all sides and from the whole globe. So, the
media coverage that should be given,
your opinion, you who frequent and
occasionally appear on TV sets,
give me your opinion, that is to say, do
you think that
journalists are up to the
problem that we are going to be forced to
confront? Is it, for you, a breach of trust? Or, to put it bluntly
and somewhat
vulgarly, are they a bit dim-witted,
or is it an editor
who's being held
by
the balls because their boss
works in finance or has
interests in it? So, that's a
question that  It seems a bit
generic, and what do you think? It's
good that they're
starting on Thursday, as soon as
the media coverage
equals the political coverage. We have
n't had enough people in politics or in the
media
who understand
these mechanisms. When we say, as we just
said, that the only thing in
shadow banking is the same as the
gang, that's inaccurate.
I'm not telling you what I've been in
banking for a long time, but I finance
billionaires, people who have 5, 10,
30 billion dollars at their
disposal, who therefore work with
entities without going through banks, and
that's very complicated to manage. So I
say that first, it's a subject that's
constantly evolving; second, it's a
complex technical subject; finally, the
real information is held by
central banks, which release
very little of it, and it requires digging
deep into what's happening inside
the banks and in global finance. Is that
a call to hackers
you're making there? Yes, okay,
Gégé, it's just a
question, made for me with  All these
billionaires, how come not
one of them transforms a little
into Batman? Why isn't there a
billionaire who decides to take
justice into his own hands? That was his
philosophy; he would never have become a
billionaire. As a child, I'm still
putting things into perspective. I'm
absolutely sorry, but there was, there is still
a good part of
shadow banking. It's the banks he
organizes with things
based in tax havens, and they're all schemes.
So, I understand that
originally you have a billionaire,
except that the billionaire calls his
buddy at Goldman Sachs, and they
show a little surprise, but okay. And so, and somewhere,
if Goldman Sachs is one of the issuers
of these products, for example, he will
pay the risk. It is indeed borne by
the bank at one point or another. So,
I'm not sure there isn't a significant
separation between
the banks and the RSA (French welfare system). We imagine, of
course, that it must be a
management function. Then, regarding the
media, I would quite agree with...
The real problem is that it's not so much
the media,
ultimately, or the journalists. They're there to moderate
debate. What's
catastrophic is the
parade of so-called experts—Mr.
Pigasse, Mr. Attali, etc.—who
come to spout nonsense. Who
are these people? The level of expertise is so
low it's simply catastrophic.
These people constantly advise politicians—
Alain Minc, Attali,
Dominique Strauss-Kahn, all of them. They're
constantly advising states and
politicians, even though they're not very bright.
We're fortunate, frankly, to have
Hervé de Carmoy today, who also has a
foot in the
Trilateral Commission and is supposed to
advise leaders.
Hervé, what does the Commission actually do
besides meet without inviting us?
The Trilateral Commission, which is
35 years old, was created by
David Rockefeller, Georges Bertoua, and a
prominent Japanese figure.  To resolve and manage
tensions between America and Europe,
and I know this is the origin of the
conflict of interest, you want to
liberalize and all exports in
Japanese dollars, we don't use them, and so we
spent years finding a way to...
you want to
eliminate banking controls in the
United States, we're not going to do the same
in Europe.
You still have mixed feelings, with a
very negative tone, towards the
Russians. We Europeans have a
slightly different view of the Russians and we think there's room for
negotiation.
So what
we do, what we
discuss, our conflicts—I was going to say,
related to our past, our position, our
resources—in financial matters,
we are
separate from the United States because we don't
need the United States to
find dollars; we already have plenty to
spare. So we need them much less.
We need them in what way? We
need to be informed. There are
banking intelligence services and
intelligence services in general. Between
Europeans and the United States, it works very
well and thoroughly and limits certain
risks, but there is intelligence
on individuals who are...  The
financial drama is a hallmark
of the last ten years, and we're not told what to expect.
We only learn about it
when the bubble bursts. My dear friend, at
Primo, is
60 billion, one of the Europeans and
Americans, giving to private individuals. The
Americans barely warned us,
so it's a
power dynamic, and our power dynamic is at a disadvantage because
we don't know how to be
politically unified in
Europe. We are in a state of
weakness compared to the United States. And you,
the Trilateral Commission, don't you
want to change it to a
Quadrilateral Commission, adding a little more
internet? No, no, no, no. We already have enough
trouble. We brought
China in, and
the number of differences of
opinion between
Europeans, Americans, Japanese, and Chinese
on geopolitical issues—
how to deal with Russia, what to do with
oil, how to prevent large
developing countries from finding themselves in
double difficulty due to the rising price of the dollar—is a
major problem. We have a lot of
trouble with the Americans; they aren't
very interested in
Europeans. They don't want to talk
with Europe; they prefer
individual dialogues with them.  leading with such a
group, but he's only moderately interested in
Europe, so our influence on the
United States is limited. Why? Because
we don't have an army. But we must
recognize that
the central element of
American culture is the army. It's through
art, but they integrate
all populations. It's through
art. But I know, here's the
right word to integrate: the buyers. Well, yes,
disintegrated or vaporized. Olivier, Philippe,
Philippe, the first point, microphone, the floor.
I'm going to jump back
to
the initial question, which was: and the
media in all this, are they doing their job?
The question is obviously
complex on several levels. First, let's
suppose we're dealing with
honest journalists, which is the very least we can expect. We should
also use their competence to
investigate the area where they're
asked to dig a little. But very
quickly, an honest, upright, and
effective journalist, a Robert for example,
immediately runs up against Semur, not to
mention the opacity surrounding the Clae Ring, which
The opacity of the
Fed's accounts, which haven't published the
money supply for five or six years now, is taking place in Luxembourg. There's
total opacity regarding the Fed's
gold reserves;
for 30 years, no one has been able to know what's
in the vaults at Fort Knox or in New
York. No American congressman has ever been
authorized to investigate
what's
really in the reserves
of the American central bank. So
what journalist can do to achieve this,
since even the
highest-ranking politician—let's say even the
head of the American Congress—can't
go with a commission of inquiry and say, "Okay,
now the Fed
needs to be transparent. We
need to know what the
central bank—the Bank for
International Settlements, the central bank of central
banks, in a way—has, which
manages 70% of the world's capital flows. From
time to time, it
publishes because it's one of the
things it makes public.
For example, it publishes the outstanding balances of deferred payments, and that's why
I can cite a
figure of 7%."  5 to 750 billion,
however, we don't know exactly what
risk each bank is running
individually. We know roughly that
the second largest bank has something
like 50 out of 1 trillion in outstanding loans,
that is to say, 30 times the GDP of
Germany. We know that some banks
have absolutely phenomenal assets, but
we don't know exactly what
these outstanding loans consist of, or what
the associated risk is. So, for a
journalist, it's incredibly difficult
to get information because
the central banks themselves are
totally opaque, and because there's no
political way to obtain the slightest information from these supposedly
completely independent central banks.
So, we're off to a bad start. The second thing is
the media; who owns it? In the
United States, naturally. Well, reading more,
the most blatant is Fox TV, with
journalists who reign supreme, like
those who claim that in Paris, there are
two areas where
Muslims can no longer go. We have
other groups like Liberty Media, which
owns several newspapers. There, we're
dealing with people  Those who truly understand
how the system works—well, the
owners in France who
today own the world—it's
a trio: Niel, Pigasse, and now we
discover that L'Express and
L'Expansion
are ultimately owned by Patrick Drahi, who
puts his investment banker from
Morgan Stanley at the
helm. So,
L'Express and L'Expansion have 24
real-time news channels. So you
see, information
today is very much under the
control of people who understand
the system very, very well, how it
works. Will these people
recruit pitbull journalists who
will dig deep to find out how
tax evasion is practiced in
Europe, how banks take
bankers, how they take
impossible leverage, etc.? It's obvious that you'd
really have to believe these people
have an immoderate love for
transparency and for
information in the noble sense of the term to
say, "I'm buying a media group so
that these people can really do their
job and reveal to the public how
things really work." Let's go!  Don't worry,
they were all at the demonstration
for freedom of expression. However,
Olivier,
yes, to say I have chestnut hair,
you want a former
budget minister, but what has become of him? Never mind,
nice phrase.
on our political model because it smelled like the end of the line,
no, it didn't smell like the end of the line,
a bit more
competent than that anyway,
he said finally in France, France
is a political system, the French is
an elective monarchy
influenced by a discreet oligarchy, if
we look at it, it's quite, it's quite fair, on
our democracy, democracy, we know
very well that in 2017 and a girl is born,
you're going to have
a candidate from the MTQ, you can be a candidate
from the PS, there will perhaps be a Marine Le
Pen who will ensure the victory of one of the two
directly, which amounts to pretty much the
same thing, so we see that the
selection model was quite biased, moreover
we know the candidates a little, which
is quite disheartening in terms of going back to
the future,
so there you have it, we have a real problem, already
avoided by democracy, by those at that time, in
addition with a total of hours, Philippe,
not to mention the rise of extremism in
what we are experiencing, well, we
are already there too when we disregard the
2005 referendum, you have to  It's incredibly
extreme to do that when you
deregulate the entire banking system. Did you,
Philippe,
mention earlier the learned Hinton who, in 1999, advocated
regulating banks by
eliminating laissez-faire? But
why? Because
American bankers, you read that in part, and they've been
regulars in France for 15 years. Oh yes,
France is the first country in the
world to have perspective on its banks since
1984, or rather, banking law since
1945. So we see that we're in
systems like this, that they
are extremist on many
points. There are
millions of unemployed people. Explain that you'll have to
work more without being paid.
My friend, who doesn't like me socially, and from an
economic point of view,
it's already a job; there isn't enough for
4 million people. So if you do
n't pay them, there will be no one to
buy what we produce. We have ideas
that are also extremist.  Being friends isn't just about being on
one side of the
political spectrum, and the second point
Kim made was a reflection
by Noam Chomsky, who works extensively
on propaganda models. He
said that propaganda is only used in
democracies, while the truncheon is used in
dictatorships. Obviously, in a
dictatorship, for her, there aren't too many
questions, which she doesn't agree with.
But in a democracy,
we put ourselves in a
situation where we are, at least in a
non-liberal democracy, we
could also say—and this is very
fortunately very different from a
dictatorship—it will be necessary to
shape public opinion so that
people, in the United States, the 90% of the
population who are being fleeced, have to
accept it. So, all in all, it doesn't happen by
itself. Of course, there's no
conspiracy, no misstep, no getting
into those phases, but as
Philippe said, there's a kind of [unclear]
among them, either in media outlets that are
healthy, that are extremely limited
in number, well, as they say, it's still
crazy.  All our media outlets are
owned by five or six billionaires.
Opus is a billionaire; he's busy. If
he really invests in
successful companies, like everyone else, he invests in
boots that don't work. You
really have to have a love of information,
which is still commendable. And then it's
astonishing that once they have these
media outlets, the media are much
less critical of the system that
allows billionaires to
buy
the system, the democratic system. So, in the
end, we have a form of
compartmentalization, a form of plutocracy
that, in
my opinion, masks itself behind a
pseudo-democracy. Ultimately, it's hilarious.
I know, to know in
2017, if we'll
still have François Baroin or
Emmanuel Macron as the communist of the economy, saying, "That's the
political difference." Yes, we can choose
between the two. I remind you, François
Baroin, Segal, UMP. I'm specifying because
otherwise I don't really know. Quite a lot has happened, more than you
might think,
so it's quite disheartening.
Ultimately, we do have
journalists who have
changed a lot sociologically. We're
far from the journalistic model of the
70s. What was it like back then?
Someone with a fairly
average level of education, but who was a parent
or someone who wanted to spend hours
drinking and reading Hemingway and other people they'd meet.
Today, we have
someone who had six possible qualifications, went to
Sciences Po in the provinces, and then thought, "Hey,
I'll go there,
especially not making too many waves." What
I do is, moreover, the hierarchy lets me
know that it's not very good,
since the hierarchies spend
their time in the century
and in an insular world, which is really, really
very astonishing.
The question is, why do we ultimately
let ourselves be treated like this? Why do we accept having so little, even
on the
information side? We could demand
things that are more, more, more provocative, but we
arrive at a situation that is still quite
paradoxical. We have the generation
of the people in history, truly the
best educated, good heavens! There is still
the proportion who have studied
compared to...  Fifty or a hundred years ago, we went from having
uneducated peasants to
a remarkably educated population, yet
ultimately we have a
political system that is utterly hopeless.
I remind you that a century ago, there were
Victor Hugo, Lamartine,
Jaurès, and Clemenceau in the National Assembly. They were
n't necessarily representative of
the entire population, but
at least they were there.
Today, with Nadine Morano and Harlem Désir, there's
a real issue here: why have we
come to this? Because, let's face it,
it's funny, but they're the ones
running the
system. François Hollande is running
France, and in a system
that is undoubtedly the most powerful in France, the
president sends the most people
who decide everything. We see that we've essentially
recreated Louis XV or Louis XXIII, working
when he feels like it, and when he does
n't, we wonder who he's with. These are
questions that arise. What a beautiful
time we've had!  Dressing up
politicians and the media for winter
is all well and good, now we're going to look at the current situation.
The dream isn't working right now, so let's
move on to solutions.
I'm going to ask each of you to
try and propose some solutions. We'll
start with Hervé. Just before,
Hervé, you can get started on this. I'd
like to discuss investments in the
United States, where we are...
well, there's
one area where it's declining
massively, which is
innovation.
Innovation in the United States has been declining for the last eight
years. Private sector investment has gone from
$100 billion to $15 billion
last year.
Publicly funded innovation
was still there, $100 billion eight
years ago, compared to $50 billion today. So we
can say that investment... but from
this perspective, it's
worrying.
Never before has there been so much money
available in the United States,
including various investment funds, and
the contrast is striking.
We have financial managers
Businessmen who are sitting on
fortunes ranging from 5 to 100 billion
dollars, and who are sitting on them—it
was a meeting of them—and there are some who, in
18th-century France, spoke of their
noble lineages. They talk about their noble lineages
and what tens of billions of dollars
they fall into, and what it would take
to
continue accumulating. So we have here a
slowdown in investment. The
most difficult thing is
real estate investment, which is picking up because it's the
foundation. That's how we attract all
these people who come to the
United States. They have colossal advantages
in borrowing through mortgages. They are given
all sorts of advantages and made to
dream that in thirty years,
the apartment they have or the house
they bought 150 miles away will be worth a fortune.
So, a slowdown
in investment, difficult,
massive investments by large
American companies worldwide,
extreme financialization.
Just before moving on to the search for
solutions, if we find any,
I would just like to say...  To put it simply
for the average person,
when we talk about
Mario Draghi, the
ECB governor, talking about injecting 1 trillion euros,
which represents roughly
until 2016, what, two billion
a day, something like that, is 60
billion a month, or 2 million, a margin
for recovery. So, concretely,
apart from inflation, what will this
represent for the average
person? Nothing,
or very little, because the average person will
be impacted if the banks that
will take this money or receive it
are willing to
invest it. And why are the
banks investing less? But I
ask you this question for a reason, there are
three reasons. The first is that to
invest and create jobs, you
need entrepreneurs. They're leaving, yes,
by the hundreds. In
Belgium alone, 500
French entrepreneurs have arrived in the last three
years.
Send them back to us! Send them back!
We ourselves were on a
bus, the
coaches, and you won't cure Dacron. I
am quite ready to help you, but
I can't  Doing all that, well, there are even more
who have gone to the
United States, England, and a few to
Switzerland. So, here's the point that's
causing the most problems. Okay,
you were talking this morning about 40 billion,
not the 40 billion that France will have to
repay to the country, the Greek debt.
Yes, that's what she's thinking. To
think that Greece is going to
repay France 40 billion
seems optimistic to me. Now, this is the
banker speaking, meaning he's a
delusional, gray-eyed man. They ca
n't... they would have to
rethink their economics. There should be debt forgiveness. All of this is happening.
Everyone is fighting to prevent all of this.
So, I don't have the
solution for Greece. Look,
Mr. Pigasse-La Harpe, he said,
he said, you shouldn't repay it
anyway, it has no consequences.
So, Mr. Pigasse has the
solution: you don't repay the...
no one who lent you money and
it has no consequences, so know that
today everyone listening
can go see their
Lazard banker. I have to, I'm going to 2 million.
Mr. Py, the aces, said it had
no consequences because it was
on your balance sheet, so I'll take the liberty
of not repaying you. Everything's fine,
Mr. Pigasse always has a
good solution, and Chad made him dance.
Regrets, and his regrets, which are
extremely
stressful for the financial industry,
for governments, realize, given
his seniority, if
we did a 50% haircut on
Greek debt, it could
ultimately cost Germany around
20 billion,
maybe 27 or 28. A
few days ago, the central bank
announced that it would inject 60
billion per month
until September 2016. The orgy
via the port of Reprenant is a joke
because initially, and they thought it
was an island.  4080 billion that would
be injected, Allanon,
September 2016 included. Harbig, that's not
1060, it's 1140, 60 billion more.
But this extra 60 billion just
arrived, plus it's a gift. There you go,
we can wipe out the Greek debt overnight. It's these
extra 60 billion that the ECB put on the table. It
stops at the Greek debt completely. Well,
we're trying to tie our brains in knots right now with
a
story that shouldn't even raise a
question. Why should we
continue to pretend that the
Greek debt will be repaid? We've
known from the start that it never will be.
And I have a wonderful example from
history: the
bankruptcy of the water company at the beginning of the
18th century, I think it was between 1700,
1715, and 1720. So, they created money, a lot of
money, the bulk of which
was actually the bonds of
the East India Company, and 7 cases where this  The East India
Company was putting
money on future wealth, creating
wealth that obviously never
materialized, at least not that. We abandoned
Louisiana, we sold it, but initially we made people
believe that there would be
money coming out that would allow us to
repay the debt, to cope with the money
created. In fact, the plan was this:
you bring your gold, your silver coins,
and we give you paper money based on
future wealth. The
day
the water system went bankrupt,
collapsed,
we had a very close call because there were
deaths on Rue Quincampoix. Things were
heating up in front of Mr. Law's bank, and what did we
decide that day? We decided on
something incredible, inconceivable in our
time: we decided to reimburse the
poor, those who had brought a few
gold coins and who, like their mothers, thought they were
rich, and then suddenly, who almost lost everything.
We
reimbursed the poor. If we had done
that with Greece...  2010, but there would be no more
worries of any kind. We would have
simply shown a kind
of solidarity or a kind of sense of
social reality, and we would have
completely extinguished the Greek debt, just as we
repaid the poor, the
Greeks. Today I'm driving, I'm playing this
role, dependent on 18, on
1720, and the Portuguese, and the Portuguese,
and so it's this canyon. So here we are again,
we are again in this
moral principle
of selfishness, of every man for himself, of
individualism. I cut, alas, it has nothing to do with it. It's about
having a hacker,
lucidity. Hervé will bet on your
meetings with the Ubrich, the ultra-
rich. So this sense, without breaking the
secret of the gods, are they
organizing themselves, and are they, a little bit,
history repeating itself with
revolts, with people with pitchforks
outside their homes, who are sketching out,
arranging a plan B far from everyone,
with a private militia or things like
that, and gold coins, and the
coins in the  The reality for these people is that they
are safe
from
the Americans. No
American government would ever tell someone, "You
have $47 billion
in various tax havens. You
declared it and wanted to keep it.
You're giving us some to
help others." I don't believe that. I don't believe that there is such a thing as a growth of freedom right now.
We were just talking about
equality, about freedom. There is no
growth of freedom anywhere in the
world that deals with even a
microscopic increase
in fraternity, especially with the most
disadvantaged. This feeling is very weak and does
n't interest Americans. On the
contrary, they have many donations, they
have a dynamic, efficient sales force that
wants to create money and leaves it
to individuals to give it according to
their preferences. My best friend
is a woman who has $150 million and
for the past fifteen years has dedicated
that sum to sick dogs.
So there you have it, it's her freedom, it's her
money, the right to do what she wants with it.
But there  The idea of ​​solidarity and
fraternity is very weak, so I think
we don't have much
hope here. Actually, my
question—I misspoke—was about whether they are
driven by the fear
of a large-scale social revolt,
and whether they are preparing a
plan B for an exfiltration.
This question raises something that really surprised me:
Google's private police force,
paid by Google in California, has
a specific
employee evacuation plan.
So if a
revolt happens there, the police are
ordered to evacuate Google staff.
So, there's no question about whether
fear is starting to take hold.
It was obvious they were
all taking measures. What kind of measures do they have? They
have their own personal police forces, their own
private planes. They can leave in a
few hours for Canada, which is
infinitely
more lax in all these areas than
other countries, of course. Okay, let's
move on to solutions. Yes,
I would have just liked to make a...  A quick
note on Greece: the Socialist Party,
and you don't know much about
Greece, just a few moments ago, with the
stupid part,
the fact that two of the heads of the
economic department are
sharing London in the City, reassuring the
markets by explaining that
what were previously promises not to
repay, at the
level of electoral promises, are
ultimately going to reassure
the markets again by saying no, it's going to be fine
because it's a
scam. The thing is, it's Hollande who's
saying exactly that we've boosted
finance and that it will have influence in London right
after to sell his wares. It's
marketing, pure and simple marketing. So there you have it, they
told Rose, on the
line, that we won't repay
the debt, and that's the first visit that
rushes in, and to the London bankers, so
lower it. What's surprising is that it
surprises you,
but there you have it, it's marketing, that's
the principle of my friend Crassus, very
succinctly, some solutions, we'll start
with Philippe.  Are we
reinventing the Freedom Braz?
I think America remains
the leading country today,
so I'm going to make a suggestion,
which I obviously don't believe in at all, since I'm not
convinced it will ever happen.
But I'll give the floor to Barack
Obama,
who made a proposal very
recently, at the beginning of February,
which was to tell
American multinationals that there are 150,200
subsidiaries in tax havens. Well, I know more
or less what profits you've
offshored.
Its rival measures 1, nevertheless. And I
propose a deal: either everything
you have abroad, which I've
estimated by cross-referencing, is
taxed at 14%, yet you'll
continue to
move your money between Dubai, Singapore,
Luxembourg,
Ireland, or any other tax haven
that suits you, but I'll still take
14%. Or,
another deal: you
repatriate all these
colossal profits. A good Apple is worth 180
billion.
Facebook is going to be in the top thirty, there are
colossal sums to repatriate,
and I'm going to give you a sort
of
2-for-2 tax
amnesty package. You
bring your money back to the United States, and
I'll tax it at 19%,
and then you're all set in the
US. We'll find
other arrangements, but what I'm particularly struck by
in this proportion of
14% or 19% that Obama is proposing is the
question of whether the
acceptable tax rate on a
global scale might actually lie somewhere
between these fourteen 19% options. Because
today, with an
average tax rate of 8% for multinationals in the
SNP 500, Eurofirst, or Euro
Stoxx 600, we realize that no
state can survive.
States will be deprived of resources,
so everything is essentially beyond
their means, not because they're being
extravagant, who has seven or  eight
years, but simply because for the past
seven or eight years, since
money was injected back into the system and
companies have rebuilt their cash
reserves and
extraordinary profit-making capacities  Well, we
see that
multinationals have completely
outsourced their profits and no
longer pay taxes in those countries. So,
is this homogenization of
tax systems and mobilization still
going to be 14%? That's still
twice what
companies pay today, but with this 14%, there are no more
deficits anywhere,
and we're reducing the number of
people on food stamps by
two-thirds very quickly, for
example, Olivier Delamarche. I
think if he proposed this, it's because he
knows it won't pass, since the
villages are
still free, and in fact, it doesn't
serve much purpose.
Furthermore, be sure that companies
will be able to circumvent this by
buying back their own shares, so it's not very
complicated to miss out.
I'll also pick up on what
Hervé Yahi was saying a few
minutes ago about
investment, and that's what's extremely
serious because it's what's coming
today for companies.  They no
longer invest in the only thing
they invest in, which is their
own shares, because they're given
free money on one hand, and
so it's quite easy to invest it
with a return of three and a half
or four times that, which is simply the dividend.
So it's
true that it's rather
pleasant; it makes the shares go up, which
enriches the company's boss, so
everything is fine, or rather, the main
shareholders of the company, and so everything is fine,
except that it jeopardizes the future.
When there's no more investment in
research, what are we going to
produce tomorrow, the day after tomorrow, and the day after that? And
I think that all
countries are experiencing this, more or less, but it's been
exacerbated in the United States because they
have this system that allows
companies to buy back their own
shares. Let me give you a
small idea: in 2014, it was 750
billion dollars, which is still significant.
So that's a lot of money.
The equivalent of the AC
Bourges pebble could practically be the
Bank of Japan's backside, there's quantitative
easing and all that, it's all about share buybacks,
so it's used to
camouflage the results. You have
bad results, but if you
reduce the number of shares, obviously
they turn out to be good. So, and that's
really a problem because it's a
long-term problem. I
think it would take years. I think we can, we could,
we could quite easily
solve this with taxation, simply
push companies to invest
with lower taxes
when they invest
for the future rather than when they
spend their money on
buying clothes, their shares. I think
that there we could hit them hard with taxes
and that would all steer them in the
right direction. So there are things to
do, but unfortunately, they are
never listened to. Wolker gave
some ideas. We should indeed
separate the
investment banks and the
retail banks. We should regulate a little
more. The financial madness should be
stopped.
The accounting  A creative solution that allows us to make
profits appear where there are
losses, that's it,
finally, and to make it happen, and unfortunately, to
try to, because I have doubts
about that happening, we would still need to
find some
politicians who are up to the task, that would be
good,
and
unfortunately, I think we're going to have trouble with that,
we could also blow up
NASA, that would be very interesting
because what comes out
of that institution is just catastrophic,
so blowing it up, no, but where to
bomb them with LSD, for example, and
so no, I think there are
many things to do,
but also stop selling completely
idiotic stories like
one day Greece will repay, we don't care about
the waters, not repaying a debt
because it's not a big deal, the ex-star, all that, we have to put an end to it, we
should inform
people, educate them so that
when they put their ballot in
the box they don't do stupid things, and they give
us the propellers, not
scooter couriers, Hervé, solutions, and the
last word will be reserved for Olivier
Berruyer, what do I take away
from this discussion
for France,
for another country?
One thing is certain: we must
prioritize entrepreneurs and not drive them away. There are
hundreds, if not 15, of
French entrepreneurs who have
left. So there's a
huge suggestion to rent buses to
bring them back to France, so from Millas as
well. I would like to add to this
relevant question
by saying that we French must stop
thinking that getting rich is bad.
We have taken to heart a phrase from the
Gospel where it says that it is more
difficult for
a
brain to go through the hole in the sky than for a
rich person
to go to heaven. Let's forget that. Let's forget
that phrase. I don't like the rich -
I like them because they create
jobs, because they can be
generous. I note that in Belgium there are
more foundations than
in all of France, and that
without that seems very good to me. The second
thing I take away from the states  United is
a personal experience I haven't
mentioned. I'm saying in three points there.
Brain, the associates created
a small organization 15 years ago
where every year they recruit 7 to 8
people who directly assist
immigrants. Each of these people is assigned
a specific immigrant, whom they see
every week or every two weeks. They provide
financial support when
possible, and offer advice on how to pursue
studies. The result is that the
hundreds of thousands of immigrants
arriving in the United States are not
only supported by the state or
states, but by individuals who want to
help them integrate.
I would say that this
generous approach aligns with the third word
of the
national motto:
liberty, equality, fraternity. And if
we took the initiative to promote this
kind of behavior, our country
would be much stronger. Olivier
Berruyer:
Yes, well,
to jump in, I also think it's
important to
perhaps remind people that the
richest of these have ultimately contributed to
the idea that...  Getting poorer is
n't necessarily a bad thing, and the future
risks showing where I'd like to
rehabilitate the idea that losing
half your fortune isn't so bad
when you're a
multimillionaire, especially if it helps
a good part of the
population.
It's less of a worry. I encourage
everyone to reread La Fontaine's lovely fable, "
The Cobbler of Financiers," which
is very interesting. Those at that level, up there,
you have a joke about the
question: what was the ultimate
solution? I think that was it.
I think he doesn't have one,
and we need to stop selling this kind of
idea to the population. I
think it's dishonest. We're in
a system that's completely out of control. We did
very well in 2008; what could that
lead to? We did absolutely nothing
after 2008, so there's no reason for us to do anything
before
the next crash, one that risks being
quite catastrophic for finance. We
're on a plane;
the pilots...  François Hollande doesn't have a pilot's
license, he spends half his time
with his buddies, the flight attendant, so, well, I'm telling you,
what's the solution? Well, the
solution is maybe to have a
pilot group. We're
on the plane, there's no
pilot, so then the next step is, what happens
then? It's going to
crash,
except there are crashes where everyone survives, where no one survives.
And it's true that
maybe in the next step, what
could happen, what
could trigger a
big financial crash? It
could be banking problems, it
could be geopolitical problems, it
could be Syriza deciding in the end
not to repay the Greek debt because
I remind you that if one day they
decide, the day before they'll promise
on their hearts that they'll repay, so
we can't foresee that, but it could be
anything, that's the beauty of
this system, it could be real estate.
In China, which is collapsing, it could be a
huge problem. In Japan, it could be a
tsunami, it could be an
earthquake, it could be anything and everything
in a system that is extremely
fragile, a financial system that plays
with sums and risks that amount
to tens of billions of
dollars and that are absolutely
unrecoverable. This is what the states are talking about. So, it's this
kind of question: what
could happen to
the parks? People were talking earlier about
Rue Quincampoix and the
bankruptcy of a Democrat from Aude and the
1740s. You have to understand that for 80-90%
of the population, which is pretty much
everyone listening to us, there won't be too many
problems with
their assets. Why? Because they
have so little in the end that we can
always repay them. If I take the
French public debt, 70% of the
French public debt is held by 10%
of the population, and at the
wealthiest level, those 10%. So, if we say we won't
repay it...  70% of the French debt,
90% of people will be
repaid, so if you have less than 10 million euros,
less than fifty thousand euros, there's
no problem, there will always be enough to
repay you. Obviously, your
friend with 175 million dollars, who
knows,
maybe one day her
Caribbean bank will be told it's not
bankrupt, in fact there's nothing left.
It's this kind of thing, who can dream,
who can dream. In any case, in my opinion,
it would be interesting to debate rather
than saying, "Yes, I can give you
a series of 50 measures that would be good
for 1 billion and 600 years." It won't happen
in a political system that is
completely compartmentalized and an
information system, we've talked about it, that
is completely blind.
Between the fools and those who can't
speak, it pleases almost
100% of the media. That's why we
have debates that will be so
interesting on the
internet. I don't take it.
The species, but we see that despite everything, there are
people who are looking for
information and who manage to find
it on this medium, but which
unfortunately will remain unknown to 90%
of the population. So the relentless bombardment will
continue. This kind of debate, which can
be interesting, is about what's happening
with the next crash, rather than
thinking like this about Rabat, what would it take
to prevent it from happening? Well, I haven't been
dug up de Gaulle. You're
trying to take his DNA, to
clone it too, you'll put it in a
sheep, you see what they know, but
these presidents... and then maybe there will be what's
needed to understand
the problem, and the problem is in
front of us, and the problem is... so I don't know
when it will happen, in a month, it
could be in a year, maybe in five years,
if sewing magic printers, and a
Mario Draghi managed not to blow up
the ECB by making the Germans leave. In
fact, to summarize your own at the
CCCC, this inability to foresee, concludes
Rob, is
a solution  That's the way out, but we're
in a system where when I introduce
globalization, when I introduce the
Transatlantic Trade and Investment Partnership (TTIP), when I introduce what I
call the
Brussels organization, which is there to
try to put all countries in
competition, we're prevented from exercising any
popular sovereignty.
When I introduce a single currency,
when I get to that point, I only have one
possible policy: Gattaz's policy. There isn't
another. This
policy will just lead to a
depression and [ __ ] the system.
But the system couldn't do much
about it. It's pointless to
say, "Oh, my enemy is finance, what's going to
happen in 2010?" It's the
same thing, actually, until... well, let's
say, it's all there in front of
us. The question is, what
can I do? That's what might
interest people, to
try to minimize
risks if things go wrong, and to
avoid having
one of the obligations.  Greeks, one of the
actions of banks is not to put more than
fifty thousand euros in a
bank, that's the kind of thing that
can be interesting for
people, to say, well, what should we do?
It would be good if I were... if we had
settled the banks sitting down like that, if
people weren't greedy. 6, 1, that's for
sure, but in the meantime, the problems are
ahead of us and the horizon is quite
near. Yes, I have a very short month, so in short, first of all,
I am...
today, every time this
question... it makes me think of the guy
who jumped from the 40th floor. There,
instead of asking him if he's going to... he's going to... it's okay when
he passes the third floor,
they tell him what he should do...
so he doesn't jump three
floors below... and I still
tend to say, he shouldn't have jumped in the first place,
because there's not much
to do when he's more than
three floors down, he's going to crash
miserably.
The second thing, where I have just a
small reservation regarding this...
Olivier said, "Is there enough
savings among the richest 10%
to pay for everyone else?"
Yes, if it were only the debt, but
unfortunately, it's leveraged, and this
debt is therefore today. The person with
their small savings plan, life insurance,
etc., will be in Reims, just like everyone else, for the
simple reason that there won't be any money.
Because if we only consider the... yes,
the sponsors correspond to the
debt, yes, but only to the debt, not the
leveraged... there has been... and the
financial products... the day there's a
loss, it will be much more significant. The
day there are
bank failures, it will be much more significant
than France's simple 2 billion debt.
But what science is about is
continuing... we make another resignation...
all the shortfalls that are also in
return for each other... the
seventy thousand seven hundred thousand
billion in derivative products, certainly ceded as
counterparties, mostly between the
banks... if one day you tell me
that all the commitments... the
banks are released from all commitments...
there remains practically...  Nothing more, since
all of this is betting, a kind of
reciprocal insurance. In
derivative products, you have
insurance on CDS collateral. If tomorrow
you say the CDS are finished, the
banks won't pay you. Release
from commitment, the entire
CDS derivative product market is over. It's just
that you no longer have insurance on
the people who thought they would be reimbursed.
But even this part about derivatives
is something to be careful about. So, I think there has been an
excellent lesson. I
think it wasn't attacked in
nature. Well, wake up! There's an
excellent question. The sound that was the
BNS. There are people who thought they were
covered too, except that they weren't
covered because there was no
exploitation. So all those who had
placed stops, and that's to
limit their losses, ended up
with gigantic losses. So be
careful about that. We often think we're
much more covered than we are, okay?
But we also saw in Cyprus a
beautiful communist experiment, since that's what
is  Right in front of us, you know,
where the aftermath of the bankruptcy of
almost the two biggest
banks in the country, but
practically the only two banks in the
country, admittedly with European aid
behind them, well, in the end you set the
deposit guarantee at 100,000 euros, and then
all the people who had 5
million euros in their account, they must still have
200 or 300 thousand left, that's just a
part, we agree that the
previous problems, Logan, that's nothing at all, what's
interesting is when
it doesn't announce itself as something to commit to, it's like
when Société Générale
loses 5 billion, it's simple, there will come a
day when it will be 500, what will happen, what will
happen is that we won't be in good shape, that is to
say, the French state won't be able to
put in the years, approximately, we are
already heavily over-indebted, so
it's all a question of
proportions, when you owe 1000
euros to your banker you have
problems, when you owe him a  billion
euros, he's the one who now has the
eyes, that's it, it's always the same
thing, so it's all a question
of proportion, okay Hervé, one last
word, one last word, last, a friend, the last, last, is to
say that
pessimism is about feelings,
optimism is about will, and that there is no
inevitability,
we can, through different
mechanisms, isolate ourselves from a certain
number of events, and we can
manage our French
financial, industrial, and social inner life
with prudence and discernment, which
we have been doing for half a century, so I
believe that the problems have
increased, that we did well to
talk about the United States because it is the
center of the problem, and that we can
organize ourselves
to
anticipate this new crisis which may
come but may also not come,
and that it does not have a deleterious impact
on all of us,
gentlemen, thank you,
from the moment we allow
operators to do what they want on
the network, in fact we allow them to
modify society, we allow them to
modify the way people
interact with each other, are better, there is
More and more opportunities, more and
more knowledge and talent,
more and more solutions, and more and
more capital for projects—that is to
say, what is currently lacking is that
many countries have
evolved their institutional framework to
include civil society in the debate,
and we are very far from doing that in
France. Just
think, the institutions are so fearful.